après une fin de semaine de réflexion en
famille Dominique Anglade jette l'éponge
j'ai informé le président du parti ce
matin de ma démission à titre de chef du
Parti libéral du Québec
j'ai annonce également que j'ai quitté
mes fonctions de député de Saint Henri
Sainte-Anne le 1er décembre
et lui député pour la première fois en
2015 Dominique Anglade est devenu la
première femme à la tête du Parti
libéral il y a un peu plus de deux ans
allez-vous être là
la dernière campagne électorale a été
difficile et avec le P résultat jamais
connu par le parti la pression était
déjà forte comme plusieurs d'entre vous
j'ai été déçu mais la crise provoquée
par l'expulsion du caucus de la députée
Marie-Claude Nicole a donné le coup de
grâce
du parti un certain à mes comptesments
alors je pense que le compris la
situation
d'être mini par des intrigues internes
dont les Québécois non que faire le
schisme est toutefois plus profond dans
les rangs libéraux le Parti libéral du
Québec doit opérer un renouvellement de
son offre politique mais aussi de sa
façon de faire de la politique deux
visions s'opposent une fracture avec le
passé en misant sur la transition
écologique ce qu'a tenté de faire
Dominique Anglade selon certains c'est
ça qui n'a pas collé c'est ça que le
membre du parti un bon nombre d'entre
eux ont beaucoup de résistance à faire
ce virage là moi je suis préoccupé par
l'importance de
nous renouveler comme partie libérale du
Québec alors que d'autres refusent de
faire table rase quand on dit renouveler
ça veut dire presque de commencer
au tout début ce qui à mon avis être le
cas je pense qu'il faut faire évoluer le
parti un parti à la croisée des chemins
avec un caucus déchiré mais qui dans un
rarement d'unité salut tour à tour sur
les médias sociaux l'engagement et le
dévouement de leur chef le Premier
ministre François Legault aussi
reconnaît son courage et son humilité
c'est cette dignité dont elle a fait
montre dans même dans son dernier
discours de départ à titre de chef du
Parti libéral du Québec comprenez que
cette journée là c'est la journée
Dominique Anglade la question qui lui
succédera et sur toutes les lèvres déjà
dénon circule de nicodère sophie Brochu
Pierre Moreau Marwa risky André Fortin
mais avant la course à la chefferie il
faudra nommer un chef interimaire avant
le début des travaux parlementaires le
29 novembre prochain ici Jacques Audric
chamboneau Radio-Canada Québec